عار على الديمقراطيين وعار على
جوليا براونلي لعدم توقيعها على
وقف إطلاق النار بينما يموت الآلاف من
الفلسطينيين ويقتلون تحت
الأنقاض، وقد تلطخت يديها بالدماء،
جميع السياسيين المنتخبين يطالبون إيري
بإنهاء الإبادة الجماعية في غزة، فمن
الضروري كم عدد الأطفال  كم عدد
الآلاف من الأطفال الذين يجب أن يموتوا تحت
الأنقاض ويُتركون ليموتوا في حالة تعفن في
وحدة العناية المركزة،
لذا فإن ممثل عضو الكونجرس كاهال عضو
الكونجرس براونلي يحتاجون إلى الدعوة
إلى وقف إطلاق النار لا عدالة لا سلام عدالة لا سلام لا عدالة لا
سلام لا عدالة
لا عضو الكونجرس و
أخيرًا، نحن خائفون جدًا من دخول هذا
المزيف، ولن يتمكنوا أبدًا من إظهار
وجوههم في أي
مكان